[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN SEALES: "In Transit" is a
funny and poignant new Broadway
musical which follows the
intertwined lives of 11 New
Yorkers faced with the
challenges of city life
with a groundbreaking
a capella score
by a team including
the creators of "Pitch
Perfect" and "Frozen."
"In Transit" takes you on a
journey with people hoping
to catch the express
train to their dreams,
including the stops
they make along the way.
Modern yet timeless,
"In Transit"
is a story about all
of us, set to music
that will stay with you
long after the ride is over.
Please welcome to the stage
the cast of "In Transit."
[APPLAUSE]
[SINGING]
[SINGING "DO WHAT I DO"]
MOYA ANGELA: Morning, Jane.
MARGO SEIBERT: Good
morning, Miss Williams.
MOYA ANGELA: Calendar alert.
I have requested
you, Jane the Brain
to work the regional conference
the weekend of the 12th.
MARGO SEIBERT: Oh,
I'd love to, but I
have to go to Williamsburg
for my high school reunion.
MOYA ANGELA: Hm, Brooklyn?
MARGO SEIBERT: Colonial.
MOYA ANGELA: Hm.
Guess we'll all just have
to get by without our temp
extraordinare.
Which reminds me, today I need
you to channel your powers
and proof the entire
annual report by 1:00 PM.
I know it's tight.
MARGO SEIBERT: I've got it.
I'll-- I'll work through lunch!
MOYA ANGELA: Gettin'
it done, Jane!
MARGO SEIBERT: You bet!
It's what I do.
I'm gonna miss my audition.
[SINGING "DO WHAT I DO"]
[APPLAUSE]
[SINGING "A LITTLE FRIENDLY
ADVICE"]
[APPLAUSE]
MOYA ANGELA: But just
remember, Jane, those dreams--
MARGO SEIBERT: Yeah?
MOYA ANGELA: Do
yourself a favor.
[SINGING "A LITTLE FRIENDLY
ADVICE"]
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: All right, so
let's get in the fun stuff.
I would like everybody to--
oops-- to go down the line
and introduce yourselves.
And then we also--
we're joined by Rick here, the
musical director, and Janet
Rosen down there, the producer.
But yeah, the rest of the cast,
please introduce yourselves
and what you do in the show.
Let's start here.
GERIANNE PEREZ: Sure!
Hi, I'm Gerianne Perez.
I play Kathy,
Sofie, a stewardess,
a myriad of ensemble roles.
MOYA ANGELA: I'm Moya Angela.
I play Momma, Althea, and Mrs.
Williams-- or Miss Williams,
she ain't married.
[LAUGHTER]
MARGO SEIBERT:
That's good to know.
Have I called her "Mrs."?
My name is Margot Seibert.
I play Jane.
BRAD STANLEY: My
name is Brad Stanley.
I play, or I cover,
Nate, Trent, and Steven.
ADAM BASHIAN: I'm Adam Bashian,
and I cover the two bass
roles in the show.
NICHOLAS WARD: We can tell.
[LAUGHTER]
NICHOLAS WARD: My
name is Nicholas Ward.
I play Chris and
Coffee Cart Guy.
[LAUGHTER]
TELLY LEUNG: Hi, my
name is Telly Leung,
and I play a myriad
of characters,
but I mostly play
Steven in the show.
AURELIA WILLIAMS: Hi, my
name is Aurelea Williams.
I also am a stand-by, so I
cover all the roles that Moya
covers and also [? Nina. ?]
ALAN SEALES: Nice.
And we have a couple--
oh, sorry, Chesney.
CHESNEY SNOW: And I exist.
ALAN SEALES: It's
the weather, man.
There is something wrong!
CHESNEY SNOW: My
name is Chesney Snow.
I play a character named Boxman.
[BEAT BOXING]
ALAN SEALES: I want all your
answers with percussion in them
tonight.
[BEAT BOXING]
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So there are a couple
Broadway debuts.
Raise your hand.
Yeah.
All right!
Congrats.
[APPLAUSE]
But I want to get in
the history of the show.
We'll kick it off early.
So Janet, you've been with the
show since, I guess, inception.
It started where, in 2004
was the original inception
of the show?
JANET ROSEN: It started
right after September 11.
The four writers were
friends and in their 20s,
and they wanted
to write something
that was a little bit cheery.
And they were performing it in
small clubs, the four of them,
who are not here today.
But I got involved
about in 2010,
when it went to Primary Stages,
Off-Broadway for a six--
seven, counting Chesney--
person performance of it.
It's like a six-week run.
And I came in and somehow
[LAUGHS] got sucked in.
[LAUGHTER]
And I have been leading
it forward for the last
over six years until we
got a Broadway theater.
It's gone from six plus
Chesney to 10 plus Chesney now,
performers.
And it's the first
a capella musical
that's ever been on
Broadway, so we were
groundbreaking in that respect.
And audiences are loving it.
We got a standing
ovation every night.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
The fact that it is the
first a capella musical--
were there any roadblocks for
you to get it to Broadway?
Or did it help the process?
Like "This is new,
let's put it on."
JANET ROSEN: I don't know that
a capella was particularly
a roadblock.
It's just that there are
so few theaters compared
to how many shows want
theaters, that no matter
what your show is, it's going
to be very time-consuming,
and you've got to really
stick to it to get a theater.
Because not only are there
not that many theaters,
but there are a lot
of theaters that
have long-run
shows in them, that
are there, like "Chicago" for
20 years or something like that.
So those are taken off
the market immediately.
So it's a challenge, and you
don't give up if you care.
ALAN SEALES: How many of
the cast here was involved?
Is this the first
time you were all
involved in this production,
or did any of you
get involved with
Off-Broadway and beforehand?
CHESNEY SNOW: I was involved
in the Off-Broadway show when
Janet, our fearless producer--
I can't tell you guys enough
how incredible this woman is
for getting it here.
Most first-time lead producers
never, ever get that done.
So it's really incredible.
But yeah, I was part of the
Off-Broadway production.
ALAN SEALES: Nice.
And then--
MOYA ANGELA: As soon as
it was off Off-Broadway,
I came in five years
ago, six years ago?
ADAM BASHIAN: It was
six years, and so did
I. We joined when they
started reworking the show,
and they added some roles to it.
And Moya and I joined then.
ALAN SEALES: So
what's been added?
What's changed?
MOYA ANGELA: Well, before, there
were only six or seven people
who did everything that
all of these people do.
It was tough.
I mean, it's still tough.
But it was unbelievably tough.
It was like on another level.
And I think everybody played
a lot of different characters.
Now they kind of spread out who
everyone plays, except for me.
I've done the same
three characters
since I started this
journey six years ago.
CHESNEY SNOW: Some
songs changed.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, really?
CHESNEY SNOW: Oh,
yeah, absolutely.
There was a song
called "Reunion"
that got cut in the rehearsals
of Off-Broadway, which
was really interesting.
It was about Jane
actually going to her--
she actually goes
to her reunion.
And--
MARGO SEIBERT: There was a
song of mine that was cut?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just kidding.
CHESNEY SNOW: And it
was pretty funny, too,
because I realized
the night that it
was cut because I had to go back
into the theater during tech
to grab a bag.
And I just happened to stumble
into this intense meeting
with the producers, and the
theater, and the writers.
And you could just see the
look on the writers' faces.
But yeah, it's a
challenging process,
because you have
something for so long,
and then it changes over time.
And things become sentimental.
There was a song
called "No Dental"
which was a reggae joint, you
know, [INAUDIBLE], you know.
And then "Wing Man"
has developed a lot.
Yeah, the songs have developed.
MARGO SEIBERT: There's also the
fact that now, for 11 parts,
we brought on Deke Sharon
as the orchestrator.
Is that correct?
He was brought on
after the Off-Broadway?
RICK HIP-FLORES: Yeah,
so the six-person version
was the Off-Broadway version.
And then five years ago,
we brought on Deke Sharon
to add four more voices.
And so now we have 10
voices plus a beatboxer,
so 11 people on stage.
MARGO SEIBERT: That's nuts.
ALAN SEALES: So Rick, were you--
you were doing "Fun
Home" in the same theater
while this was
Off-Broadway, right?
Or is the time--
RICK HIP-FLORES: No,
the Off-Broadway thing
was-- we're talking
quite a long time ago.
This was about 2010, was it?
So there's been a lot.
Lots has happened
between [INAUDIBLE].
MARGO SEIBERT: It takes a while
for a new musical, typically.
ALAN SEALES: And were you
involved with the Off-Broadway,
or did you come-- did you
come with the theater,
or did you come with the show?
RICK HIP-FLORES: Well,
there's sort of three stages
of this process.
There was the
Off-Broadway thing,
which was quite a while
ago, several years ago.
And then there was a
whole gestation period,
where we were doing workshops
and developing the show
in the past five years.
So that's where I kind of
brought in around the same time
Moya was, around--
was that 2010 or 2012?
2011, 2012.
Yeah, so just between then and
now, that's a whole six years.
And I think we did workshops and
readings just about every six
months, right?
Six months, we did shows at
54 Below, we did performances,
and what they call labs
to specifically work
on the material where the
writers can make changes to it.
And so that's the process
that I was involved in,
never the performance of
the Off-Broadway show.
ALAN SEALES: So
for those of you,
I guess recently, who were added
to it, or even those of you
who were in it originally, what
was your first reaction when
you heard, oh, it's going
to be an a capella musical?
MARGO SEIBERT: Uh-oh.
I don't have any
experience with a capella,
except my little sister's
in an a capella group.
And that's what I told
them in the audition room.
I was like, "My little
sister sings a capella.
I've gone to a lot of concerts."
And that got me the
job, which was nice.
No.
I mean, I love
complicated singing.
I love the challenge of this.
But I had never had a
capella experience before.
TELLY LEUNG: When I first
heard was an a capella musical,
I thought to myself, "Well, is
it ever going to sound full?"
I'm so used to
doing rock musicals,
and musicals with big
or orchestra pits.
So I was like, "How are we going
to make that a full sound?"
And actually, one of the things
that a lot of audience members
leave telling us is that they
say, "Actually, we forget--
partway through the
show, two or three songs
in, we forget that
there's no orchestra."
And that it does sound full.
And that really is a
testament to our writers
and also to Deke
Sharon, who arranged it
in a way that is using the
entire range of the human voice
so that it feels--
we are the orchestra, you know.
So it's pretty incredible.
So that fear was allayed
pretty quickly for me.
ADAM BASHIAN: We also
have some of the best
sound people on Broadway--
TELLY LEUNG: Yes, oh my gosh.
ADAM BASHIAN: --who
help mix us, and do
an incredible job of making
sure everybody's balanced,
and you hear what you need
to hear at certain times.
TELLY LU Ken Travis, our
sound designer-- incredible.
MARGO SEIBERT: Because unlike
what we're doing right now,
we have our normal
microphones that we wear,
and then we also
are wearing in-ears
like you see it
at a rock concert.
NICHOLAS WARD:
Like Beyonce wears.
MARGO SEIBERT: Like Beyonce.
TELLY LEUNG: Like
Mariah Carey wore!
NICHOLAS WARD: Or Mariah
Carey didn't wear!
MARGO SEIBERT: Oh!
Edit that out!
NICHOLAS WARD:
[INAUDIBLE] too soon.
MOYA ANGELA: Cut!
Just kidding!
NICHOLAS WARD: My name
is Justin Guarini.
[LAUGHTER]
TELLY LEUNG: But you know what?
I was watching that New
Year's Eve with the in-ears,
and my heart actually
leapt out for her.
Because I said, [GASPING]
"She hears nothing."
Now that I know what it's like--
MARGO SEIBERT: We can't see--
we don't see Rick.
Rick is in another room, and
we don't have any monitors.
So in our in-ears is a click
track so we can keep on tempo.
He gives us our pitches,
and he also counts us in.
And we can have up to the
10 voices plus Chesney
panned in our ears.
So I can have my bass over
here, I can have soprano 1 here.
There was a learning curve.
We may have broken
down a few times.
But now, that's how
the show operates.
It's kind of a technical feat.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, I was
going to ask about that.
Rick, are you in a
tiny little room that--
MOYA ANGELA: He is the Wiz.
NICHOLAS WARD: The
Diary of Anne Frank.
MOYA ANGELA: He literally
is the Wiz, in a room
somewhere, with the door closed.
We had to make him
a special room.
Serious.
RICK HIP-FLORES: So we developed
this entirely new method
of conducting a show which has
never really been done before,
and not certain whether it
should ever be done again.
So every show that you see
on Broadway pretty much
has a visual reference,
a visual monitor.
You look behind you
in the audience,
and you see that there's
a conductor monitor,
and you see the videotape.
We don't have
that, because we're
pretty much in the round,
or actually 3/4 for us,
but it's pretty
much in the round.
So anywhere where they would
have put a video monitor would
have been a little bit
distracting, so we said, "Why
don't we just try this
without any video monitor?
Just all in their ears."
So at the start of every
song, give a chord--
[SINGING NOTE]
And then "1, 2, 3, 4,"
and then they're in.
NICHOLAS WARD: Or "4."
Or [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
TELLY LEUNG: Now,
the crazy thing
for actors-- when you're
performing in a scene,
you could be in a very intimate
scene with your fellow actor,
but in your ear, you
will hear Rick say,
"2, 3, 4," because he's
counting in everybody else.
So that actually
was the part that
took a little getting used to,
to feel a little bit like you
have many voices in
your head talking
to you at the same time.
MOYA ANGELA: And getting
dressed while [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN SEALES: Because you
have so many costume changes.
And there is no orchestra, so
you are your own transition
music.
So how do you do that
with the costume changes?
NICHOLAS WARD: The
funny thing about it
is, you would think
by now-- we've
been doing this show since
December 11 previews,
maybe November 10 or whatever.
You would think by now,
you're in a groove,
and you've got your show down.
Every doggone show, I'm
tired, I can't breathe.
There's one song "Four
Days Home," where I'm like,
[HUMMING] the whole song.
Everybody else cuts out,
and I start the vamp again,
and I don't stop.
And Kathleen Marshall,
who is amazing,
has us running around
pushing chairs,
changing clothes three times.
And I'm not 21 anymore,
so, you know, it's hard.
And I think that's
the one thing that--
we all, at the end of the
show, every single night, we
finish "Deep Beneath the
City," and then we all go
[SIGHING DEEPLY].
Every single night.
Because it's still
hard, it's still work.
And I think we're
proud of it, but it's--
you don't come in, and
like a lot of shows,
the orchestra takes
you through the show,
and you ride the ride.
This one, you're on
a roller coaster,
and it's always like
[MIMICS ROLLER COASTER].
MARGO SEIBERT: I think
it is that last moment
that we remember that
we are the orchestra.
I feel like it's the final
note, we're like, "Oh, yeah.
We made every single sound
that happened tonight."
TELLY LEUNG: But you
know-- and for us, it's
such a feeling of
accomplishment, too.
But I also feel like because
our house is so intimate,
that audience knows.
They know how hard
it was to hear
11 people on that stage making
every sound for 90 minutes.
They recognize that, too.
And I think that is why
they jump to their feet
at the end of the show.
They know.
They go, "I can't believe
we just saw that."
JANET ROSEN: I come to the
show two or three times
a week, just to check up.
[LAUGHTER]
And because it's
in a semi-circle,
I see across to the
audience on the other side.
And there are people that start
to smile in the first minute
or two of the show, and
they keep that expression
on their face the whole
hour and 40 minutes.
They never stop smiling
through the entire thing.
That's how much they enjoy it.
ALAN SEALES: I
like that you guys
keep going back to every single
sound, every single sound.
And there's one of
my favorite scenes--
Kathy, you should get a close-up
on Nick's face right now.
There is a point
where, set in New York,
they do the cacophonous
sound of New York City
that I would love for you
guys to give to us now.
NICHOLAS WARD: I just
need a sip real quick.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: This is all
coming from their mouths.
NICHOLAS WARD: I'm not
going to use the microphone.
[LAUGHTER]
You You don't want him
to use the microphone!
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
do the whole thing.
Do the whole thing.
Yeah, yeah, all of you.
NICHOLAS WARD: Everybody?
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
[SNAPPING]
[LOUD SOUNDS OF NEW YORK]
AURELIA WILLIAMS:
(YELLING) Shut the hell up!
[APPLAUSE]
TELLY LEUNG: NYC!
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Thank you.
NICHOLAS WARD:
Eight shows a week.
ALAN SEALES: Being in the round,
and the audience is right up--
I mean, not on
you, but they're--
NICHOLAS WARD:
Eating cheesecake.
There was a woman--
[LAUGHS] we were
doing Saturday night.
And obviously, you
get a lot of people
that this is their first
time seeing a Broadway show,
and they go to the TKTS line.
And they're like, "Oh!
'In Transit,' let's go.
It's about a train.
so let's do it."
And so there was a
young woman sitting
on the corner of stage
right with her boyfriend.
And we were doing
[HUMMING] And she pulls out
a piece of cheesecake.
And I'm like, no no.
And she opens it up, and takes
out a fork, and is eating it.
GERIANNE PEREZ: She had Juniors.
NICHOLAS WARD: It was Juniors!
[LAUGHS] I was like, all right.
We're now dinner theater,
which is super cool.
AURELIA WILLIAMS:
New York cheesecake!
I mean, it's a part
of the experience.
NICHOLAS WARD: And
she didn't even
think anything
was wrong with it.
That's what's great to me.
ALAN SEALES: Have there
been any other weird things,
like the audience
getting up on stage?
There's no intermission, so
an hour and 45 minutes in,
people have got to pee.
MARGO SEIBERT: Well, they're
warned at the top of show
in a very clever way
done by our writers,
that if you haven't
peed now, it's too late.
You have to stay.
And for the most part, I
think that the thing is
is that if you're in the front
row, you are in the show.
You are so close, you're closer
than for the front row is here.
Which is amazing,
because it's really
fun when people are
having a really good time,
it's really really fun.
But people will just forget,
and put their feet up
on the stage, and
that kind of stuff.
NICHOLAS WARD: Or tape.
They will pull out their
phone, and I think they forget.
MOYA ANGELA: We'll remind them.
"Excuse me, lady."
ALAN SEALES: Do you
ever do that, actually?
You tell them?
MOYA ANGELA: Yes, we do.
GERIANNE PEREZ: James one
time got in someone's face
and was like, [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN SEALES: So
the show itself--
I mean, it's a big oval.
It's basically recreating
a subway platform
for the majority of the show.
And in the middle of
it, there's this--
what do you call it?
MOYA ANGELA: Treadmill.
ALAN SEALES: A giant, a
100-foot-long treadmill
or something.
Does that thing ever break?
Do you have a contingency plan?
NICHOLAS WARD: Well, I
was doing the coffee cart.
And normally, it's
like [HUMMING].
And I ride out probably
midway where the stairs end.
And for some reason,
I wasn't stopping.
[LAUGHTER]
It was like, [HUMMING].
And I'm like, [HUMMING]
(YELLING) where are we going?
And I thought-- in
my mind, I'm like--
I think as actors, we
all automatically start
to go through this contingency
plan of, what am I going to do?
If I'm jumping out now,
I have to do the rap,
and then am I going
to point to the--
I went through all of
this, and then it stopped.
And then it backed up--
[LAUGHTER]
--and then went forward--
MOYA ANGELA: And I was on
it walking in glitter heels.
And a dress-- I won't tell
you, because you've got to come
see the show.
But I was walking--
I was like, I'll
never make it home.
ADAM BASHIAN: What was great
about that happening, though,
is in shows, when
you're calling cues
like the treadmill
or the lights,
everything's on this
number system, right?
So if something gets off, that
means almost everything else
either has to catch
up or wait for it.
So all the lights started
to do the wrong cues.
So the next scene after that
is this scene in an office
building that's fairly tame.
But for this performance, it
was like working at Google!
Because there were
disco lights going,
and all sorts of crazy things
in this very intimate scene.
So that was pretty funny.
NICHOLAS WARD: They
had to shut down.
They had to basically
reboot the system.
ADAM BASHIAN: Yeah.
GERIANNE PEREZ: We hear
this very intimate scene
between Mario and
Moya [INAUDIBLE].
And then all of a sudden, we
hear [POWERING DOWN SOUND].
And Mariand and I
are facing upstage.
And we just grabbed
hands, and were like,
it's the end of the world.
We really thought we were
about to meet our match.
NICHOLAS WARD: I
thought this was--
I always think the world's
coming to and end, though.
CHESNEY SNOW: But that's the
beauty of live theater, right?
It's something always--
AURELIA WILLIAMS:
It's the beauty?
[LAUGHS]
CHESNEY SNOW: Yeah!
Well, because I feel
like the audience
then feels like that's
the magic of live theater.
AURELIA WILLIAMS: Yes,
they're part of it.
CHESNEY SNOW: That's
not going to happen--
MARGO SEIBERT: Well, you
always remember the show
where something went wrong.
Patti LuPone hit the light
bulb, and it exploded,
and glass went
into the audience.
That happened during "Gypsy,"
and everyone was like, "What!"
NICHOLAS WARD: What
about the guy that
plugged his phone into the set?
"Hand to God?"
He thought the set
looked like a normal set,
so we plugged his phone
in during the show.
Yes.
And they were like, "You idiot!
This isn't real!"
AURELIA WILLIAMS: It's a set!
ALAN SEALES: Climbed up
on stage and plugged it
into a prop outlet.
Did the first production
have this, the treadmill too?
Or is that recent--
only for Broadway?
JANET ROSEN: It's
a very small stage.
It was probably half the size of
this platform, the whole stage.
ALAN SEALES: No kidding.
JANET ROSEN: Yeah, it was an
Off-Broadway theater, very
small Off-Broadway theater.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, you guys
make use of the whole stage.
And to put it on half of this--
yeah, that's hard.
That's really good.
Chesney, I want to go to
you for a second here.
You've had a very
interesting history.
You-- if it's okay
to talk about this--
actually were homeless
in a previous life
we'll call it, right?
CHESNEY SNOW: Yeah, that's
why I moved to New York.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, now
starring on Broadway.
You want to touch on your
journey here, how you got here?
CHESNEY SNOW: Yeah, I
mean the interesting thing
about this show for me is
that my life has always
been in transit.
We were always moving
from one place to the next
through childhood.
And yeah, we had some
difficult times as a child.
But I was in Arizona, and I
had found myself homeless.
And I was in a homeless
shelter, and they had this--
it was like a barracks, you
know, so it was all men.
And it was a really interesting
glimpse into America,
to see the various
people that were there.
I remember there was a father
with his 10-year-old son,
and the son was on
the bottom bunk,
and the dad was on the top bunk.
And I was just looking,
and observing at how
everyone was interacting.
And I remember there was a
guy in a wheelchair with--
both of his legs were gone,
and half of his arm was gone.
And he held his POW flag
high with the American flag
on the wheelchair.
And I just remember
having that experience was
this giant leap for me
in recognizing what I
wanted do in terms of my life.
And just really being humbled.
And yeah, I was sitting there.
And I had just finished doing
"All's Well That Ends Well,"
so I had a little bit
of money in my pocket.
So I was trying to find out what
was I going to do with that.
And it wasn't a lot of
money, summer stock.
You guys--
So yeah, so I decided, I'm
going to get on a Greyhound bus.
And if I'm going
to be homeless, I'd
rather go be
homeless in New York,
because that's
where my dreams are.
And so I got on a Greyhound bus.
And a friend of mine who
was also doing summer stock,
he had went to
ACT San Francisco,
which is the American
Conservatory Theater there.
And I had met him
during "Julius Caesar,"
and I had got in touch with him.
And he was like,
"Well, you can stay
at my place for a month or two
until you can find a place."
This was 2002.
And yeah, so I got
on a Greyhound bus
and made my way across
the country to New York.
And that's how I started.
I started by actually spitting
poetry on the streets,
and selling jewelry
on the streets.
That was how I ate
when I first got here,
and I just worked my way up.
So by the time that I read the
script of "In Transit," which
I had been in New York for
almost 10 years at that point.
And they say that it's
a 10-year journey.
I've heard this rumor.
And I read the script,
and I was like, "Wow, this
is kind of like my life."
I was like, it's finally
a role that I'm right for.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
I want to come back
to this for a second,
but if anybody
has questions, you
should start lining
up over here,
and we can take your
question in a second.
There was-- for the [INAUDIBLE].
CHESNEY SNOW: Oh,
look at that light!
The light.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALAN SEALES: That guy
has to ask a question.
[LAUGHTER]
So for the last 10
years or so, you
were saying that you've been
doing some education as well,
right?
CHESNEY SNOW: Yeah.
Me, and I think there are a
few other teaching artists--
I know Moya also, we
share this passion.
Because, well,
when I was a kid--
when I was about 13,
14, my family and I,
we were homeless, my
sister and my mom.
And so I got to this place
called Platteville, Wisconsin.
And it was an
English teacher that
really turned my life around
by giving us a Shakespeare
assignment.
And it was in that
Shakespeare assignment
that I was first introduced
to the magic of theater.
And because I was
in a place where
I didn't have much
self-esteem, and being
the only black kid in the
school, I was kind of isolated.
And so theater was a way for me
to feel confident and escape.
And so I really feel
in a lot of ways
that it saved my
life in many ways.
Really, it did.
Because it gave me
an understanding
of my own brilliance.
There's so many things in this
world that can tell you you're
not brilliant,
you're not brilliant,
you're not brilliant.
But there are so many different
types of intelligence,
as I'm sure you all
at Google are aware.
But yeah, so I always
wanted to give back.
So I've been working
and teaching beat--
I teach beatbox at the
Lavelle School for the Blind
with my man Taylor McFarrin,
another great a capella artist.
And we use beatboxing
as a way to help
students who are blind that
have multiple disabilities
communicate.
So we started that
program there,
and that's still going strong.
And then I've been working
in the New York City
public schools as a teaching
artist for about ten years.
ALAN SEALES: That's incredible.
There was something you
said in an interview
I was watching last night.
You said, "You may
not like everybody.
You may not know everybody.
But everybody is
singing backup to you."
CHESNEY SNOW: Yeah, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Just wanted
to leave that right there.
It's important for
the corporate dynamic.
Yeah.
Take a question?
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
Thanks for being here.
First of all, you
all sound incredible.
I'm really excited
to come see the show.
A few of you mentioned
that you have
no previous a
capella experience.
Have you found that you had
to change the way you sing?
I mean, especially if you
have Broadway backgrounds,
you're used to belting, or
doing the star in the middle
of the show thing.
MARGO SEIBERT: Oh, god.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Have
you found that you
had to change the way
your voice sounds, to fit
in with this kind of a sound?
MARGO SEIBERT: That's
a great question, and--
TELLY LEUNG: Yes.
MARGO SEIBERT: I do
do this in the show.
Absolutely.
So with these kind of
intense orchestrations
that Deke created with
our 10 voices together,
we are serving you
musical instruments.
So there's a lot of time when
vibrato isn't necessarily
appropriate when
you're streamlining
sound to make a very
specific instrumental, yes.
And also then to
blend with everyone,
because if everyone's vibrato's
going at the same time,
you know, it might be
really fun and less--
and less good.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah, there's a--
Telly and I both
share the [HUMMING],
like when we're making a--
what is that?
Is that a bass?
TELLY LEUNG: Guitar.
MARGO SEIBERT:
It's a bass guitar.
So yes to your question.
TELLY LEUNG: It
is hard, because I
feel like in a
traditional Broadway
show, as a soloist,
you want to ride up--
I feel like I'm trying to
ride above an orchestra
at all times.
But in this, oftentimes, the
blend is what's important.
Everybody singing the same
vowel is what's important.
And the discipline
that it takes-- that
took the longest, actually.
This is actually much harder
than actually belting a tune
to the back row of the theater.
This is much harder.
NICHOLAS WARD: I think in
a normal Broadway show,
you start rehearsal day
one with music rehearsal.
This one, we started
music rehearsal
before we started
rehearsal, where
we sat in a room for eight hours
a day for almost two weeks--
MOYA ANGELA: "In Transit" jail.
NICHOLAS WARD: And it was like--
and I think for a lot of us, we
were kind of like, "Oh, my god.
How am I going to sing
for eight hours everyday?"
And thank god Rick was
so cool, because he
knew when we started
looking a little crazy,
we need to take a break.
He did.
But at the same time,
he slowly started
creating the foundation
of the show, which was us
not being soloists.
And really making
sure that if you
can't hear the person sitting
next to you, then you're wrong.
And he would say it with a
smile in a nice, nasty way.
On Thursdays, it was
a little extra shady.
MARGO SEIBERT: Shady Thursday.
NICHOLAS WARD: So we
have now Shady Thursday.
[LAUGHTER]
But that's how the
foundation of the show was.
And I think it took us
all probably a good week
before we retrained our
voices and our minds
to think of singing a show.
Because normally you stand in
front, and you sing the song.
Now it's really,
we're all one body
supporting the people telling
the story in front of us.
RICK HIP-FLORES: As a
point of comparison,
no show that I've ever done
has ever had more than two
or three full days of
rehearsal at the top.
So we started with
10, and I remember
writing to Kathleen
Marshall at the beginning.
I said, "Is this correct?
10 days of rehearsal?
10 days, eight hours a day
of just singing, sitting
in chairs with music stands?"
And she was like, "Yeah, yeah.
You can do that."
And I was like, "Oh, this
is going to be murder."
But by the end of it,
I was so optimistic
going forward, because they
put up with it so well.
I mean, that takes
a tremendous amount
of focus and concentration
to learn a score like that,
and with these 10-part
harmonies for basically 80
hours of rehearsal straight.
And the fact that
they could do that
made me know that they
could do anything.
NICHOLAS WARD: We would all
go home and cry at night.
I'm not kidding.
I remember-- normally, you get
a score, and the score is--
what is it called?
8 1/2 by 11.
Our score-- because
it's rectangular.
TELLY LEUNG: A4 paper, and
it's printed horizontally.
NICHOLAS WARD:
Horizontally, thank you.
TELLY LEUNG: 11-part
harmony the entire time!
So you're constantly
just flipping pages.
It's a little insane.
ALAN SEALES: Is the beatboxing
written on there, too,
or did you get to make
up your own thing?
CHESNEY SNOW: I'm sorry?
ALAN SEALES: Did you get
to make up your own thing?
Everything you do
every night, is it set?
It's locked in?
CHESNEY SNOW: The beatbox
and the score is set.
I mean, it's
developed over years.
So at first, there really
wasn't percussion just laid out.
We were exploring and
building it over the years,
mostly Russ Kaplan
really laid it down.
And so yeah, it is
written now, there.
ALAN SEALES: That's crazy.
CHESNEY SNOW: It had to
start from somewhere.
ALAN SEALES: So there
is-- oh, go ahead.
GERIANNE PEREZ: You guys
developed a lot of that,
though, in that
first 10 days, right?
CHESNEY SNOW: No,
I think it was just
over the Off-Broadway
for a lot of the songs,
and then through the
developments that we did,
the readings and stuff.
ALAN SEALES: So the a
capella genre, I guess,
subculture, within mostly
college-age people,
I would suspect, has a very
specific set of groupies,
and followers, and whatnot.
Have you found that has
transitioned to this show?
Do you have a capella groupies?
GERIANNE PEREZ: We've got
some pretty great Fansits.
We like to call them In Fansits.
NICHOLAS WARD: I
didn't know that!
GERIANNE PEREZ: Yeah!
There are a couple
of people that we
see at the stage door that
have come quite a few times.
And they're just so happy that
they get the chance to see it
over and over again.
Because what they say is
that there's so much going on
on the stage, because it's
such an ensemble-based show,
they can follow
different things.
Every time they come and see
it, whether it's five, 10 times,
they'll see something different
and hear something different.
And that's kind
of really lovely.
ADAM BASHIAN: One of
them gave me a note once,
which I thought was adorable.
GERIANNE PEREZ: Yes,
I got a note, too!
ADAM BASHIAN: Because
I was on for--
I don't think I was--
I think I was on for David.
And she says, "Oh!
When the redheaded
guy does that,
he usually goes this way."
NICHOLAS WARD: Oh,
that kind of note.
ADAM BASHIAN: OK!
GERIANNE PEREZ: Noted!
Duly noted.
ADAM BASHIAN: It's like,
"well, I go this way.
Thank you."
No, it was very sweet.
But yes, they come quite a bit.
NICHOLAS WARD: You know she's
going to be back in that stage
door with another note.
AURELIA WILLIAMS: It's
interesting to go in
as a cover.
So me, Bradley, and Adam--
we all cover more than one role.
And so it's kind of interesting
when you go in for something
that you're not
the normal person.
And so coming out,
there's this guy.
He's a young guy,
kind of a big guy.
I don't know!
He came, he was like, "This
is my fifth time coming.
I saw you last time you were
on as the woman in the leopard
print, and now you're--"
And I was just like, "Wow!"
He's made it to--
and when I would come
out, while I was on,
I must have seen him at
least four or five times.
And I was like, "How'd
he have money to do that?
That's amazing!"
CHESNEY SNOW: I
also think that it's
another reason that
it catches on, too, is
because unlike a lot
of Broadway shows,
this is really New York's show.
I mean, if you're a New
Yorker, if you've lived here
for six months, you're going
to find elements of your life
in this show, because
New York itself is
a character in the show.
And so I think that people
love to come and see
those hustles, and that
struggle, and that joy,
and the quirks of what
it is to live here.
NICHOLAS WARD: To that point,
too, I think a lot of people
come thinking a
capella is the show.
I think people think that--
early on, we did a
talk back, and people
thought they were coming
to an a capella concert.
And I think actually, a capella,
even though it's amazing,
and it's a really cool
feature of the show,
I think the truth is
really the heart of all
the different stories,
and it's so relatable.
And it's so tangible
for every person.
Every person at the stage
door-- old, young, black, white,
Asian, we get them all--
they all really attach onto
different parts of the story.
And that's what's,
I think, to this day
that's still resonating so
much with our audiences.
And why people come
back, because they
might be somebody that's
now going to school
on their second career.
And they're like, "I was Jane.
I was trying to do it.
And I didn't get my break."
And so therefore, they come
back, and they're like,
"I want to see it again,
because she's living my story."
Or the gay couple.
I'm from the South, so I
know a lot of that stuff.
And there's a lot of
people that feel that.
And so it's really, I think,
the cool thing about our show.
ALAN SEALES: One more question.
AUDIENCE: This isn't
really a question,
but my mom and I have
a tradition where
every few months, she
comes to visit me here,
and we see a Broadway show.
And the last show that we saw
was actually "In Transit."
And when I told her
that "In Transit" was
doing a talk at my
work today, she just
told me to forward
her compliments
and thank you guys
for what you do,
because we really
enjoyed the show.
MARGO SEIBERT: Thanks, Mom.
NICHOLAS WARD: What's
your mom's name?
AUDIENCE: Aria.
NICHOLAS WARD: Hi, Aria!
Thank you!
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So thank
you for coming.
I wanted to come
back to this idea
that New York is a
character in the show,
because this is
one of the things
that I really enjoyed about it.
But we walked out of
it saying, is this
going to limit sort of
the reach of the show?
Is someone who comes
from rural Kansas
really going to enjoy it as
much as someone who lives here?
And have you seen any of that?
MOYA ANGELA: We get that
all the time, though.
We get big groups from--
CHESNEY SNOW: Brazil.
MOYA ANGELA: And
the thing about it
is, yes, it's a New York show.
But the stories that we
tell, and the situations
that are happening on stage
are super relatable to anybody.
And so it's just something
everyone can connect to.
CHESNEY SNOW: And
just to add to that,
there is this thing
that I always--
because I hear that, too.
But one of the things that
it's important to remember
is the iconic
nature of this city.
It's like, I remember
being in Bhutan
and seeing people with
the New York hats on.
I mean, literally, in the
mountains of Nepal and seeing
people, seeing young kids
who-- that country pretty much
just got opened up to
YouTube not too long ago.
But there's this--
unlike most cities,
New York has this
larger than life brand.
And so I think that
when you come here,
it's easy to relate to it.
My family came from
Oklahoma City--
completely related to the
show, because of the nature
of what New York is.
MARGO SEIBERT:
It's also stories--
sorry-- the stories that
they've heard about the subway.
It's like, then you don't
have to ride the subway.
You can just come
see "In Transit."
And I've had people be like,
"I've heard of that happening!"
And they feel like
they're part of it, which
is great for out-of-towners.
TELLY LEUNG: I mean,
at the end of the day,
these are very human stories.
And the thing about New
York that makes it unique
is that it's the
humanity all on steroids,
because we're all, the
millions of people, all crowded
together.
And the common denominator
happens to be the train.
AURELIA WILLIAMS:
The subway, yeah!
TELLY LEUNG: No matter
how much money you make,
and who you are, sometimes the
fastest way to get from point A
to point B is the train.
AURELIA WILLIAMS: It's
the most efficient.
TELLY LEUNG: Right!
It's the most efficient.
So I feel like it's very
human stories, just told
in a setting where it's
humanity on steroids,
is what I think of it.
AURELIA WILLIAMS: I mean,
I'm from New Jersey--
[AUDIENCE WHOOPING]
--which-- oh, hey!
Jersey in the house!
I live in Connecticut
now, though-- ooh, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
But what's funny is even in
New Jersey, it's not that far.
I grew up 20 miles from Midtown.
And we came out, but
we didn't come out
that much, and just because of
the apprehension of New York
being this big,
scary place where
somebody's going to rob you.
And, you know, the subway
is a big, scary place.
I think that the New York
story part that you see,
it's something that you get
whether you've been here
for 10 years or 10 minutes.
When you come in,
there's a certain thing
that you are
slammed by, and it's
part of why you travel here.
And I think that people get it.
You know?
They get it.
NICHOLAS WARD: It's why
"Friends" was so famous.
GERIANNE PEREZ: And
"Sex in the City."
NICHOLAS WARD: And
"Sex and the City."
Not everybody that watched
"Friends" or "Sex and the City"
lived in New York, but
yet the comedy of it
is they're caricatures
of life experience.
And that's why people are like
"Oh my gosh, that's crazy,
and it's funny.
Oh my god."
Because it's true.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
we are at time here,
so I want to wrap this up.
Go see them at Circle in the
Square at 235 West 50th Street.
InTransitBroadway.com.
On Twitter and Instagram,
@InTransitBway.
But before you get up--
I would love it-- could you
guys do one more song for us?
AURELIA WILLIAMS:
Sure, we can do that.
I think we could do that.
[APPLAUSE]
[SINGING]
[SINGING "GETTING THERE"]
[APPLAUSE]
TELLY LEUNG: Thank you, Google.
MARGO SEIBERT: Thank you!
[APPLAUSE]